back for the last session of the day so
this is the third talk in the EP in
stats course
so Rachel Cummings from Georgia Tech is
gonna start out by talking about work on
private synthetic data generation and
then midway through Velvia so to Rio and
Setia will come back and talk about
other applications
so Rachel yes so I am the first half of
the last talk of the day and I want to
thank the folks who are like officially
supposed to be talking for sharing
overtime today I'll be about half this
session and we'll see so I am talking
about privates privates pathetic data
generation although maybe this should be
more of the title a computer scientist
perspective on statistics maybe question
mark I was previously in a computer
science department I'm now in like an
Operations research and stats department
and I'm still learning the language of
statisticians and so I really do feel
like I approach this field from a sea s
perspective but still trying to be
appreciative of the tools given to us by
the rich field of of SATs I do have a
minor speech impairment so if I pause
briefly during the talk I promise and
not just daydreaming
all right and so up until now we have
been thinking mostly about forms like
this how we have some how we have some
particular database we have some
analysts and she wants to like him ask a
bunch of things about her data until she
finds some like aha sound like
hypothesis huh this is a good fit on on
the data now we're gonna switch to
thinking about something like this and
so it's the same model except instead of
outputting a like I'm hypothesis she's
going to produce a brand new database
they'll hopefully share the same broad
statistical properties with the original
database and because we're here we're
gonna think about some kind of like
privacy preserving barriers might belong
here or it might belong here
I think I don't need to motivate in this
room why we care about producing data in
a way that is differentially private so
I will assume that we all agree that
like that's an important task so like a
few things that I'm just gonna talk
about today I'm going to talk briefly
about like why is this an important
problem why is it not enough to just
output on hypotheses and I'm going to
spend the bulk of the time talking about
some like current tools that we know how
to use to like a privately produce data
and also things like we as a community
can be thinking about particularly in
the next semester and like beyond is
we're all here thinking about about this
broad topic so why should we care about
generating x' pathetic data and the main
reason is it is it like that's what
people use all the time if you talk to a
em practitioner who's not a privacy
expert they don't want to learn how to
use all of your DP mechanisms and
they're used to being handed data and
just like doing analysis on data and so
really we has a privacy field should
meet that need and we should give them
some data some more like nuanced answers
is that they may not trust tools that we
give them especially
they especially if they're not
particularly interested in in like
trying to learn about privacy and they
just want to run analyses and also
allows them to do kind of like all the
stuff that they would be doing before we
don't have to worry about if there
exists like a DP mechanism for a
particular task a really nice thing
because it allows them to do anything
they want on this data sets and it will
still a preserve differential privacy
because of post-processing and so really
this is saying I don't have to think
about composition guarantees if I hand
someone privatize data then they can
just freely use it another nice thing in
practice is that we don't have to think
about filmic interaction how they first
hand a query to some like trusted
private analyst and they then like
evaluate that that and give them back
some like I'm private private answer
there's a lot of back and forth and it
would be great if we didn't have to to
like do that and then also there's
there's some cases where we just have to
publish data for example the MS and the
Census Bureau legally has to produce
micro data that looks like a database
okay so I'll now talk about three tools
that we know but first some
preliminaries in some rotation I'm going
to think about the database as being
some some X the consists of like um and
entries from some data universe n and so
this n is like the space of all possible
things that your data might be if we're
talking about like a binary data then
this is just 0 1 if we're talking about
how about you're like I'm health
information then this is like the space
of all possible medical records that you
might have and so depending on different
context this n might be very large or
very small we're going to help going to
talk about queries and the pensa tivity
of a query as we saw in the last talk is
just the maximum change you know the
value of some function as they move as
they move between neighboring databases
so you know the same except for one
person's data
and finally I'm going to be talking
about on alpha-beta accuracy and this is
an important notion given that we had a
slide during the last talk about about
how different fields have different
accuracy notions this is much more of a
computer science style accuracy notion
and it says that like with high
probability I want it to be the case
that if I evaluated some query how my
true data versus if I evaluated it on
the database produced by some by some
mechanism M and the answer is gonna be
close up to some additive alpha
questions so far on this stuff
why doesn't that just directly
contradict privacy requirements if this
alpha was going to be zero then it
probably would I guess that this alpha
is I'm zero and the beta is than it
would but this is going to be able to
allow us to like a parameterize how
close am i given this alpha and beta how
close am I to the true answer with high
probability and so this actually looks
kind of like the Pack style guarantee
that we saw how I'm saying is going to
be approximately correct probably you
got this like the yes
so the quantifier goes goes up cool well
so this must hold simultaneously for all
F but probably one is it a joker like a
real question I generally can't tell
anymore so it's saying if you hand me
some m then if then I'm gonna give you
back some alpha beta for that particular
M and so this is a property of a
particular algorithm that you hand me
yeah yeah yeah okay and so now to the
actual problem so the first thing that
we're going to talk about is a small DP
and this is by like plumb to get Roth
back and I'm two thousand eight and this
takes in some some particular database X
and it's going to produce a new database
Y of size that depends rhythmically on
the size of your query class and it's
going to depend for some desired
accuracy alpha it'll depend one over
alpha squared
and it's going to and it's going to like
achieve this in a very simple way it's
just going to sample some small database
why hence its name it's going to sample
some why in a way that is like
exponentially biased towards things that
match that match F for all for all
possible queries in this class for those
of you familiar this is really just an
instantiation have the exponential
mechanism only we're going to output a
like database and so more formally
here's here is like the same thing put
in like an algorithm form so it takes in
database in a query class accuracy
parameters and privacy parameters now
we're first going to write down every
every possible database of size log ass
over like alpha squared you should be
concerned about this and I'll come back
to that next and then for each of those
is going to assign a quality score which
is sort of like how well would I be
doing if I published this Z has my
database and it's just going to be be
like a worst case performance overall
FMA query class and you like additive
difference of that F evaluate it on the
true database versus on this like small
DB Z and we're then just going to sample
some Y with a probability proportional
to X of this epsilon times the quality
score all over two times I Delta F
okay so it's very simple I just write
down all possible database' isn't a pick
one that is good you should be concerned
about this step because they have to
write down all possible databases and so
it takes exponential time and it's like
exponential and a thing that is small oh
and this log should be on the top it's
not log at the entire thing but it's log
on the top so it's so is exponential in
log it so this says as long as you don't
have too many queries that you want to
evaluate it's fine but maybe I should be
concerned about this like exponential
and the accuracy guarantee health
squared and the performance guarantee of
this I'm going to state things thank you
to gout them for talking about what this
see upfront means for them computer
scientists
this is just a like big theta if you
don't like that there's some constant
time to lists this stuff and so this
small D P is going to be epsilon
differentially private and it's also
alpha beta accurate for this alpha and
so it depends log on a lot of things and
that's nice all over epsilon n to some
one third third power and so this alpha
looks like 1 over n to the one third and
so going back to this now I have this
like alpha squared and we're now
starting to get n in the exponent and so
if you have a very large database this
is going to take exponential time
so some pros are that we have like very
strong formal accuracy guarantees I can
tell you they're going to have this
accuracy for all queries in your query
class F do gave to me up front that's
great
cons are that it takes a really long
time to run and you only get accuracy
for this like pre specified query class
and make no guarantees about the
performance for the other queries that
do not belong to F and so it can be like
arbitrarily wrong on those titles of
queries for which this is more efficient
so if you're if you're clear class is
small then it's good and if your input
database is small then it's good and
also if you don't care about getting
very good accuracy then it's also good
very useful yeah there's no large query
class which has some structure enables
maybe one thing is if like the log F can
be replayed by VC dimension of FN I
guess a decimal i adjure yeah yeah yeah
and so if your query class has some
structure then this log F can be can be
leaked can be like replaced by the like
VC dimension and so then this might be a
smaller thing you still have the problem
of n but yeah it's basically you should
not try to use this in practice for any
kind of like for any kind of like big
data things
um okay so it's great in theory not so
useful in practice one more tool is the
private Plunkett of weights algorithm
and this comes from heart and and um
Hoff Blum back in 2010 and for this
we're gonna have to shift our thinking a
little bit about about what like a
database is and we shouldn't think about
it as being a list of like entries one
for each person but instead we should
think about it as being as being a like
I'm histogram and I'm gonna count how
many people have a particular data type
and so this like X is gonna be the
fraction of the database entries that
have type I for i from 1 to the size
many data universe and so again is this
is like binary data and equals 2 and
this is very small if this is like a
person's medical record and is extremely
large and again it depends on like how
you plan to actually this algorithm
works by just maintaining a like a
public histogram why the kind of
reflects all the current things that we
know about the input database X and it's
going to be like iteratively updated and
so eventually this Y is going to move
like closer and closer to X over time
and here's how it works
when a new query F arrives I'm going to
check if this query evaluated on the
truth database versus versus on the
public histogram Y is close up to some
additive alpha guarantee and if it is
close then I can say this is in fact
easy because the like public thing the
world can see is giving me a like a
correct answer and so I'm just going to
say go check Y because that's like I'm
all the information and it won't cost me
in my privacy budget if it's not if they
have very different answers I'm gonna
say half is hard and I'm going to and
I'm going to like output tough effects
on the true database plus some noise and
I'm then going to update my like a
belief about why I'm slightly lying here
because I can't exactly do this but
instead I have to like check if things
are like easy versus hard in a private
way and I'm kind of like uh sweeping
that under the rug but it effectively
works like this once I have no more hard
queries in my class then it must be the
case that for all queries that I care
about answering I have an approximately
correct answer up to this alpha term
instead of telling you in math how this
update works I'm going to show you a
picture because I think those are always
nice so I start out with some like a
public database why and imagine that on
my first query Isaac over predicted and
my answer was like I'm too large well
this means that in putting like too much
weight on some things and like not
enough weight on some other things and
so this means I should like push down
the push down the weight I have on the
types of data that will make the answer
to that query large and I should
increase the weight on things to he'll
make the to make the answer to that
query small and so I go from this to
this
on the opposite hand if I under
predicted if my answer on why was I'm
too small then I should do just the
opposite I should now like I'm increase
the weight on things
who will make have have a larger value
on why and I should like decrease the
weight on things that will make us have
a smaller value on Y and so I will end
up with something like this and so this
is the update rule that will be
performed here every step and so as soon
as I find a queer that I'm doing poorly
on and then going to update and
incorporate the fact that I have that I
have been doing poorly on this and I'm
going to update according to this like a
noisy answer and so really because we
couldn't stop as soon as we've seen as
soon as we have no more hard queries and
the goal is really to show today like I
don't have that I don't have like too
many hard hard things and I can
eventually just um stop updating and I
will have reached this stage per my Y is
approximately correct
oh there was supposed to be animations
but alas okay
so here's the entire slide okay and so
this like I'm accuracy guarantee so we
have had this his like epsilon
differentially private and it's alpha
beta accurate for this alpha the main
thing to note is that it like looks
pretty similar to the one that we had
before I still had this one third power
I still have things on my log and I
still have like an epsilon and on the
bottom and so this is good and the proof
of this accuracy guarantee relies on I
am on I am Angela argument showing the
as we update as we have more hard
queries then my why is going to converge
to my X approximately and I won't have
too many hard queries in the process and
you might think is that bad that we're
converging to the truth database that
seems to be like I'm inconsistent with
the goal of privacy and this really is
due to the fact that we're thinking
about things in like I'm histogram form
and so I'm not thinking about like a
list of people's data but rather I'm
thinking about a count like I'm how many
people have each type and so for example
if I say say that like in my true
database I have like um it's like I'm
sixty percent male or eight percent
female it means I'm going to like a
converge to that but maybe I'm going to
end up with like you know 58 and forty
two math yes good okay but that fact
will not really help me to just like
reconstruct individual entries in my
database and so it's like okay to like a
convergence of things approximately in
the histogram sense where it's not
really okay to like I'm converged in the
list sense
this is very hand paint wavy you know
the tribe said by this but I'm I'm
speaking I'm sweeping a lot of things
under the rug I feel like part of it is
also that you just if there are no more
hard queries you just wouldn't look you
may not come for it like your public
history may not cover to the actual
histogram if you're not asking all the
card query secession yes yeah and so in
fact it's important that it won't
converge exactly to X but it will
converge to like the thing that is close
to 2x but because you stopped as once
you have like I'm alpha accuracy you're
not going to keep pushing and try to
achieve alpha over two and so you're
guaranteed to be to be in some small
radius around X we're not guaranteed to
achieve exactly X and so that's kind of
like a critical point it's also like
close to X as measured by the query
result those queries close taxi
like I feel like I miss that when is it
hot if your public histogram is not
correct on that on that query and so I'm
going to maintain this thing publicly
and that's viewable by the entire world
and I'm going to like to like I'm check
because my F approximately correct on
why if yes then it's easy because I'm
already doing well and if no then it's
hard because I'm doing poorly on it and
so therefore I have to like them update
according to that query with respect to
life yeah the current y as well mention
this idea of like a verification server
so you can actually imagine like now
you're seeing what Y would give you and
asking the verification server am i
correct and occasionally it will tell
you to know and you will reincorporate
that information into Y and the
surprising thing is that after a bunch
of like no you're not correct
they'll be correct in perpetuity and so
pros of this approach are that we have
again formal accuracy guarantees I can
tell you precisely what alpha you have
and that's great and it runs in time
linear in the size of the data universe
x accounted a hard queries and we bound
these insane factors not to - um - um
many of them and so that's great
the con is that well this n might be
really large again if I'm thinking about
about some like very large document well
I can have a whole bunch of those and so
this may still be unreasonable for some
applications and again we still only
have accuracy for the pre-specified
queries and we have here a little bit
more we have here a little bit more
flexibility compared to the small DB
approach where there you have to spaz
five queries up front all at once here
here I can choose them adaptively as I
go but again I get like I get like no
accuracy guarantees for the queries that
I haven't specified
all right and the final approach is
private Gans which is a completely
different approach and so for those of
you who don't know generate generative
adversarial networks or organs are
really just like two competing neural
Nets playing in a zero-sum game and
there's one who is a I'm generator and
their job is to like produce medic data
and the other one is the on
discriminator who has given some data
and then has to I decide if it's the
true data or if it was created by the
I'm generator Andy's like um and these
um neural nets are both going to like um
iteratively update their update they're
like edge weights using a stochastic
gradient gradient descent and so the
picture looks kind of like this I know
it's small on the screen so there's some
like oh there's some kind of like I'm
kind of like input space into G and
that's going to like create data and
send them to D and I'm also going to
have like some real data and that's
going to go into D as well and D has to
guess if the data the disease comes from
the true data or from G and then DS
answer goes back and helps like both of
these things update update they're like
edge weights and again these things tend
to converge well in practice
how to privatize these so it's actually
quite simple we really just have to like
add noise in the gradient update step on
both of these networks we actually only
have to add noise to two MD because it
turns out D is the only one who can see
the raw data from this step and then
like everything after that is just a
post-processing and so that preserves
and that preserves privacy and so it's
okay if we train G regularly and D we
have to train privately and it's
possible to undo that but just adding
noise into the gradient in the update
step there are some tricks happening
there like you have to like clip things
to make sure to make sure that there's
founded sensitivity of the gradient and
of course there's a lot of like tricky
things happening here that I'm not quite
saying but it but it like essentially
boils down at a high level to just this
core idea and I want to also point out a
few things done by folks in this room so
this first paper or we have Kunal and we
have Ilya maybe is he here okay this you
and so this paper was on like a
differentially private deep learning and
so since cans are a special case of deep
learning a lot of the approaches there
apply in ganz as well and we have this
paper the first W is from Steven whoo
and and in the back they applied like a
private Gans - like I'm generate medical
data I mean that worked well and our
cell I saw you
his his on paper here incorporates like
a Bayesian framework and the real
punchline here is it like them these
things like tend to work well in
practice and so this paper or and this
graph is taken from this paper Thank You
Steven
and it's showing like two different
things that we're trying to learn so
there's this one and this one and the
red is a true data the blue is a non
privately trained can and the purple is
a privately trained can and the thing to
note is that purple performs about the
same as the red and the blue and if you
want to hear more about these things
then check out this paper or ask Steve
in he'll be around all term and so pros
here are are hard are that like it works
very well in practice like these things
work it's great the queers don't have to
be specified upfront you can just kind
of like train between your Gans and it
will spit out parameters and you don't
have to say I want to answer these
queries but not these ones
and once it's trained then you can just
share the edge weights and those edge
weights and those ed weights can be used
to then just like I'm generate arbitrary
amounts of um data so it's great some
cons are pretty major the biggest one is
that there's no formal accuracy
guarantees and so in fact the reason why
you don't have to specify things upfront
is because we can't formally tell you
they're going to have accuracy on some
queries so that's a thing that we should
be concerned about they're also very
slow to train they're fast to use once
they have been trained but the training
is very computationally expensive and
also in general like a deep learning is
kind of a black box and so then it
brings up all these other questions
about like I'm fairness and transparency
do we should be concerned every time we
don't quite understand exactly what's
going on inside of an algorithm build in
specific accuracy
by kind of rather than training sort of
an arbitrary distinguisher of the as the
yeah I'm sorry all Network to you know
ask it to look for you know it pairwise
marginals or whatever it is the feature
that you think is like some set of
important features Kunal is nodding so
I'll take that as a yes I'm not really
an expert on this viewer yeah so I don't
know I mean really what's happening is
we're using because we're using like an
algorithm that is guaranteed to perform
well had a complex problem on a
non-convex problem and we see the lake
we'd tend to reach something that looks
like an Optima but like we don't know I
think what you're proposing is maybe
broader than just private Gans but as a
question of sort of like I'm how to get
accuracy for deep learning in general
and that sounds important but that's
outside of my expertise explicitly like
the dole query I guess what I was
wondering is like is there a way to get
sort of the best of both worlds where
you're you're sort of pointing your
distinguishers you know here's a class
of distinguishing rules that you should
consider and anything else you can
figure out too I mean I guess that seems
like something
that seems like a good idea and I hope
someone tries it yeah corrected my
conditional accuracy guarantees
basically based on like the amount
privates suppose has certain baseline
accuracy can we at least have some form
of accuracy guarantees that only account
for the movies or the error of YouTube
privacy with respect to the light to the
best non private I would say very
probably I don't know if that exists but
that's that seems but that seems like a
thing that is very doable because we
know precisely how much noise we we add
because you can specify a clipping
parameter and that tells you how much
noise you add and if we know how things
like gaussians concentrate and so that
seems like a thing that should be doable
I don't don't know if it has been done
or not
I cannot defer to them my classification
here whatever like somebody's life don't
need to know sorry this is training a
generative model right Bret sure yeah
whatever likes certain accuracy
guarantees that people empirically work
with in the eye in my impression off the
often they're kind of the most campy I
think okay the images there's a transfer
body type techniques so that's a good
question to think about
yeah and there is kind of like weird
feedback happening here and so things
really are adoptive fortunately we know
that like on differential privacy
behaves well under like adaptivity and
so again this this seems like a thing
that should be doable but I don't know
if it's been done
so we have three tools the first two are
great in theory but not really efficient
in practice for the kind of problems
that we probably want to use that than
four and then we have guns that are
great in practice but there is no theory
about their performance so the first
very natural thing that we might want is
we might want some tools to like
generate private pathetic data that are
both efficient for use in practice and
still have some like formal accuracy
guarantees I think that's like a very
natural question of sort of like what
happens in the middle and maybe the like
dual query paper that I didn't talk
about I'm sorry Marco is kind of like
I'm starting to get in that point and
also Stephen - sorry and beyond that we
may also want these tools to not require
kind of analyses we want to do to be
specified in advance I want to just like
I'm hand a person data and say and say
like it's correct go nuts and and I also
want this to match analysis needs of
what practitioners are doing I'm not
really a practitioner so we don't
actually know exactly what these things
are but I think this is a great
opportunity for the theorists in the
room to to like talk to folks in
practice and see what do you want to do
and what do wish that you could do on
your private data sets and I think more
broadly and this was mentioned to toxic
oh and sessions I think is that is that
we also have to educate practitioners
about what it means we're handing them
private and that data it means that we
have like added noise and so this thing
is not the exact ground truth you may
want to do some like pre-processing have
the data that I hand you or change the
way which you do analysis so we have to
like to convince them of that
it also means there's not not really
like a one-to-one mapping between
between between the like entries and
they like original data and then this
new data that I give you and importantly
the fact that it may be accurate only on
some queries
I imagine practitioners would not like
it if I tell them here's a database and
the 10 things that you're allowed to ask
about it that seems not very useful and
so a combination of this and this seemed
like a really important need before
these things can be practically used can
you say a little bit about the
ongoingness yeah sequence of
competitions or yeah so that is so that
is this the name that I'm doing the
group of someone undergraduate and
graduate students yeah yeah yeah so
there is an ongoing NIST competition
want to be able to like a crate private
data solve exactly this problem it is
proceeding in three periods the first
one was theory and we're currently in
like a period to where they want code
it's unclear what period free is going
to be but they have allowed a date for
that so cool
and and they are and they are like
asking people to provide tools for
privates
that data generation they're getting
actually like a pretty absurd amount of
prize money people should participate if
you're interested in this and basically
NIST has a recognizable a truly find out
what our best practices for this problem
what tools exist what works and what
doesn't and so they are just very
interested in hearing from people like
us and so I think more of us should
compete in this they're currently in the
middle of a match there's two weeks left
and then a third one is going to start
in a few more weeks and you're happy to
send anyone a linked about that if you
want to hear for sure okay so here's the
nice challenge I think other think that
perhaps it's interesting and I'm sorry I
may have missed this
if Rijal said it or not the challenge I
think the current challenge that's going
on or do I think the current one is
actually on synthesizing American
Community Survey data and this is the
census product that we use to update all
kinds of estimates about the population
between the major censuses that we take
and this is a key product for the census
so I think maybe that that's of interest
but yeah just Google NIST DP synthetic
challenge and you'll get the information
and the site okay so I don't have nice
Eliza promise or whatever I'm looking at
all right so I just wanted to take a few
minutes to basically wrap up our
three-hour session and point to a couple
of additional perhaps interesting
application
that people here may be interested in
looking at and all in light of answering
kind of this question like how can we
really enable private statistical data
analysis and there are a lot of problems
that we can address there so I also want
to just take a minute to say that you
know the decisions have been working on
this problem or sharing confidential
data since the 1960s and I think you
know there were some valid and good
ideas in there and people are still
working on this it's a very active
research area and we're we're well
trained and especially you know I would
say the survey methodologies thing or
how do we collect the data and I feel
that there is much more that we can do
privately actually with this also data
collection stage rather than constantly
just waiting for all the data to be
collected and then to manipulate it and
edit it and see how we're going to share
it but there's a lot of different type
of data so I'll mention a couple of
examples regarding the census data and
synthetic data in particular I say
something with social networks and
public medical health data just a couple
of additional examples of things they
were interested in working on so as far
as the physical disclosure limitation so
I said goes back into the sixth back in
1960s and the idea there always has been
that we are again just differential
privacy we're adding bias variance we're
doing data masking and and you're either
transforming or perturbing records
attributes you're adding some noise so
there are a lot of similarities is there
in both the what we describe with
current mechanisms and what I guess some
of this statistical disclosure
mechanisms from the past are except they
are lacking some more formal evaluations
of both the utility and the risk
especially how we understand they're the
risk so more modern approaches I
mentioned this remote access servers
earlier synthetic data is definitely
something that statistical disclosure
community is very much interested in and
a lot of people are working on that and
of course there are problems with
distributed databases and secure
computations actually using the
cryptographic tools to do analysis and
distributed databases and you will
probably be surprised even how the
settings how simple they seem to be in
terms of what what type of analysis they
want to do in these distributed settings
but yet we don't really have a good
solution yet or maybe you guys do but
I'm not aware so synthetic data so we
heard about synthetic data so I don't
really need to go into details on this
again this is a technique that it was
actually initially proposed by Ruben in
early 90s and and Steve Feinberg had
some ideas also about this in early 90s
so we've been thought talking and
working and developing statistical
methodology in synthetic data for a long
time not clearly with differential
privacy guarantees so that this is what
I want to point out here so the question
came up even respect to Ganz but in
general so when she runs to create
synthetic data how do you evaluate the
utility how to evaluate the risk and it
has it's been built it was believed
until recently I'd say that any
synthetic data release especially if
it's what we call fully synthetic data
is completely safe ok there studies
showing that that's not necessarily the
case and so now the methodology
statistical disclosure limitation
community and people in this disclosure
limitation community are trying to
understand what could how to deal with
that and the fact that you actually even
from some synthetic data depending how
its produced you can have potential
identity actually disclosure ok the
question of is it valid for inferences
so how do we evaluate that I will go
through a very simple Virtual RDC exam
with synthetic data that exists but
basically it's based on the data product
the type of analysis people want to do
so there are these so called specific
utility measures so if I want to fit a
regression model I'm gonna fit a
regression model on a synthetic data set
and then I'm somebody will have to check
for me if those estimates or the
confidence intervals correspond to two
to what I would have gotten if I
actually did analysis on the original
data one other thing that I want to
mention is that in statistics the
methodology typically requires that you
produce multiple synthetic data sets
from the same data source there are some
new results on this also in statistics
saying when it's enough to have a single
data source but here I didn't hear
anything about multiple replicates
necessarily okay so let me quickly
mention something about the US Census
synthetic data so there are two
synthetic data products that people use
they're publicly available the survey of
income and program participation
longitudinal business database you all
are familiar we're on the map as far as
I know right now that's currently the
only differentially private census
product that it's available out there
and you can learn more about these data
bases in their features I think what's
interesting here if you just look at
longitudinal business data Survey income
and program you know that you have a lot
of skewness in in these data sets right
they're not necessarily a trivial okay
so how does one currently interact with
these synthetic data sets so there is a
simulated census already see at Cornell
that's Virtual RDC what does it mean it
basically simulates the census research
data center I am guessing most of you
are familiar with the research data
centers or do I need to explain
I better explain okay so a research data
center it's a data data in clave you
have to this is there a number of them
across the country these are the centers
that if you want to get access to the
original or raw data from the census you
need to put in a proposal ahead of time
saying what type of data you're trying
to access what type of survey or some
actual original census data what type of
analysis you're interested in doing you
have to wait certain amount of time
let's say six months plus in good
situations to get access to actually for
somebody to approve the type of access
that to the type of data that you're
interested in and then you go physically
into the RDC into into a closed room
behind the closed door because you've
received the permission to do so you do
all the analysis at the computer in this
research data center you can now take
anything up there anything out right and
then once you're all of your analyses
are done before you can publish any of
your results somebody there's a typical
disclosure group that will have to go
through and evaluate for potential
disclosures that the data you're trying
to publish could lead to and then that
then you could publish your results okay
so what this research data similarly
research data sensors virtual research
data center tries to do is completely
mimics the actual computing environment
that the sensor senses provides you will
have access to the sauce and our
whatever else is available so you can
design your code your analyses that you
want to run ahead of time and you don't
have to sit physically in this research
data center and you don't have to go to
this long process of being approved and
you can play with these synthetic data
sets that they have and so perhaps while
you're waiting to get access to the
original data in some cases if you some
very very simple analysis you want to do
getting the results on the synthetic
that I might be sufficient but in many
cases people are doing quite
sophisticated analysis have
sophisticated questions so they actually
have to get access to the bridge
all data so this helps with this waiting
period in preparation and so it does
help with a data sharing what I said
earlier typically have multiple
implicates of a single data set so this
is longitudinal database business
database so this is the original data
just showing some trends over the years
and the mean so that's the blue and then
I'm showing here the two implicates to
synthetic data sets and the mean of that
and how they compare to the data of
course much interesting what I would
love to have here or some kind of
confidence bounds but I don't but you
can see they don't exactly match right
so you know there will be some potential
error if even if you're doing synthetic
data but nobody really yeah I was trying
to get done in 10 minutes 15 minutes so
consistently tracking each other just so
I understand what you're plotting so
blue is the true raw data pink in the
yellow are two synthetic data sets it's
the mean of the two where is it oh is it
so you can't see it yes it's so good
purpose of asking for implicit is to
give people a sense of ounce of error
right having yes for having more than
the reason why we typically have more
than one implicit is to for you to be
able to address some some error because
by the way you create synthetic data
it's a simulation process right so you
want to be able to count for that as
well the variation between the
implicates is tiny compared to the
actual error yes the generationally so
does that kind of like me sort of make
fun of the idea of having multiple look
it's not I mean
so so okay I was gonna get to this so
one of the points that I'm making is
that people have been for a long time
the proposed that the initial proposal
from the nineties was that we absolutely
have to have the multiple implicates we
need this for the right inference
virtually to be evaluated similar errors
appropriately but there is new work
showing when you may or may not need
more than one implicit and it has to do
in part what is it that you're trying to
generate I think what I'm saying is like
suppose you generated more implication
yes like you would never get this blue
line like you would never figure out
that the shirts are all below the line
like it's the multiple implicit for this
purpose I mean for for this specific
estimation the test well what I am
saying is there may or may not be used
useless because I don't have the
standard errors in them all right we can
come back to it I mean I know what
you're saying you're saying and I mean
this is the scale here as well
but I don't actually know what the
standard error on this is for all I know
it's covering the implicates
and so consistently above all the time
and there's elasticity on top of each
other come back to the nitty-gritty
details but I and and I think another
point is that there are many different
criteria to use to create an implicit
and I actually don't know what the
specific material here was to create an
implicit and it's there are certain
decisions and saying I'm okay to be this
much off from the original data
especially if the intent is not to give
you the really the correct inference all
the time but for you to that is I never
said it's correct inference I said for
most cases people are using to test
their codes in some very simple examples
this the actual synthetic there may be
sufficient for their inferential task
depending because the the the
statistical integrity in the data that
it's preserved highly depends on the
statistical model you use to generate
these data right and so depending you
know if I've used the leap I preserve
the two-way margin sorry didn't preserve
its margins my inference will be
affected right if I'm using the
inference using using those margins okay
so okay so so typically you typically
work with multiple synthetic versions of
the original data you are doing some
kind of averaging okay to to estimate
the coefficient so as estimate the
standard errors and then for some kind
of an analytic validity check somebody's
going to check on the internal data how
well do these match okay and there's a
very general statement that says data
analytically valid if coefficients are
unbiased and the inference is the same
so in this particular setting this is
what they're measure is they want
coefficients of a regression model to be
unbiased an inference being the same
they're expecting that there's some
significant overlap of the confidence
intervals okay for that you get from the
synthetic data and the original data
this is this is a rule of thumb there
are no theoretical results showing why
exactly we do this this is more from
practice purposes and and it can be
argued these days a lot of people say
well biasness is less of a problem but I
think it also depends on a problem
you're trying to solve I'm sure that FRA
okay we'll talk about tomorrow where
actually you really want to be in biased
and so in some direction so in some new
directions people are considering this
when trying to actually prove when do we
need a single advocate versus multiple
implicates do we have some more valid
utility measures and so I we actually
have a what we call a general utility
measure so what I'm talked about looking
at the regression coefficients an
overlap of the confidence intervals
people consider this specific utility
measure okay general utility measure
wants to compare the original data with
the synthetic data so I am trying to
figure out duty can I claim that the
original data and the synthetic a that
come from the same generative
distribution and we actually have a
measure called up P MSC P stands for
propensity propensity scores and if this
measure P MSE we have some theoretical
results on this and it's bounded between
zero and point two five and I won't go
into details of this maybe I can give an
informal talk like you know when I get
back if people are interested in this
but what's nice is that we actually use
this measure again which is a measure of
similarity between these two data sets
if I've done a good job with my
synthesis I really shouldn't be able to
distinguish if a record came from
original data set or from a synthetic
data set right and this is what this
propensity score measure does okay
again saying that they I believe they
come from the same underlying
distribution so we use this PMAC measure
as a utility in exponential mechanism
and then produce synthetic data and it's
nice because it's bounded it's very it's
a good bound and we're getting pretty
good results with data and I don't
expect anyone to tell me ahead of time
what type of analysis they're gonna do
because it's similar to gains in a way
that it's just looking at capturing some
a distributional properties right I'm
not relying certain sufficient
statistics on some other parameters okay
but this is you know brand new work
we're still working on this but I think
this is a nice direction it's somewhere
I think between if the dress is perhaps
some of the problems that are just
issues that were brought up and
something that we are interested in
exploring further and besides this
measure is something that a lot of
statistic news now and this for we
didn't propose this for different to
develop differentially private synthetic
data we proposed this to actually be
able to evaluate synthetic data a
quality of the synthetic data in general
but it turns out that they had these
nice properties and there's also simple
power package a lot of people are now
using for creating synthetic data and
it's constantly in a development okay so
I am I don't want to spend time on this
I'm quickly gonna say that some other
interesting problems are networks and
relation relational data some of you
have worked on this some of the stuff
that I talked about today using
measurement error concepts and the
likelihood concept to get the right
inference you can do it for network data
the medical public health data are also
very much of interest so there is no
much work on functional data and
functional data analysis I wanna say
that Matthew rhymer is here she's
actually an expert on functional data
analysis and these are the type of
problems you're looking at so you have
really high dimensional say that from
one perspective but you know I have a
sample only if I think about actually
little n right
I'm only 200 individuals and they're all
kinds of complexities with these data
and problems and we have begun to look
at this from a differential
by the perspective and met you can tell
you tell you much more about this and
then one last thing so doing
computations on data they're distributed
in different databases we're actually
talking to this is a real problem we're
talking to epidemiologists at Harvard
who say I only have two sources of data
there's the insurance claims and their
electronic healthcare records and I want
to do a secure analysis on these and I
want to get absolutely exactly same
point estimates standard airs exact same
our output our SAS output as if you
would have if you would ever gotten if
you actually be if you were able to
combine the data and so the struggle
here is is that you know again this part
of Education me telling well you know
that's great but then if you're going to
publish those original ones you're back
at square one
etc so there's there's a lot of
interesting problems still in medical
bio medical setting and particularly in
distributed setting I know a lot of you
are working on what I consider extreme
distributed setting with individual
devices but this type of problems the
stirrups still very much what people are
interested in okay so and if you're
interested in hearing what statisticians
have been doing and are still doing and
trying to understand the disclosure a
risk assessment with survey data
longitudinal data there's actually a
webinar on February 6 well 12:00 to 1:30
Eastern Time and you only it's free you
can sign up by February 5th and I mean I
recommended if you're really trying to
understand what practitioners are
interested in and what they're doing and
and because both Tom Krinsky and
generally they have a lot of experience
with survey data this is what they've
been doing for the past you know 20 30
years okay and I'll leave you back with
a nice challenge okay
I hope this gives a lot of intro to
froggy for tomorrow morning there
further questions that the actual
population does not change from say five
you're supposed to today so you have a
very strong prior on what the data
should like should look like I'm one can
imagine kind of using that definitely in
the drive it matter to get equates to
the other frameworks kind of support a
set up where I have a strong prior on
the data and I can use that to get isn't
it
so without D peeing
people definitely use the Bayesian
framework for creating synthetic data
right but that says priors were
typically mostly non informative or they
were chosen for the computational
purposes rather than using informative
knowledge about the population
beforehand to the extent that I am aware
of that you you raise a good question
and this is some of the things like in
the network stuff with with relation
relation relational data you know how do
you weigh a relay or can we you know
that that's that's I think it's a very
interesting problem right considering
and wouldn't multiplicative weights I
guess will be away
what sort of it
beer picture question about the
synthetic data approach so we saw in
sort of the first two talks there was a
lot of emphasis on these settings where
kind of the additional error for privacy
is sort of a lower yeah we've known
since like Kobe's work in the early
2000s that if you have sort of a large
enough set of Statistics you want to
preserve then the error kind of has to
be on the same or even higher order than
the sampling error like just by starting
with synthetic data you you can't hope
to get you know say confidence intervals
for normal data that are nearly as tight
as what like you've talked about yeah
I'm just curious like how this fits into
in the bigger picture like which I mean
or is it I would think almost it's like
a non-starter because you can't get
anything close to what you could get for
like specific tests you want to run best
a meters okay so so I first first I
think that even with a current current
synthetic data methodology I don't think
that we necessarily did a very good job
in taking the the synthesis process into
consideration so the general framework
that I was describing the vishesh and I
are trying to propose that applies
regardless if you're talking about
differential differential private
mechanisms or any other mechanisms so
we've been advocating there really even
in synthetic data we have to do
something like that okay so will that
give me better if I account for that
error better so basically explicitly
knowing what the mechanism and we do
some of that but we don't do it as well
would it give me better results I don't
know your second point was or having
your do I do we really need synthetic
data what was that what sorry you're
saying when we look at like the
confidence intervals feel um - oh yes
they're saying you know with data sets
of
thousand the confidence interval even
with like all the you know cleverness
that went into designing this one
algorithm for this one statistic holes
are like twice as wide and that's you
know not great and now you know you're
talking about solving sort of a much
harder problem where we can't even get
like within a factor of two you're
getting you know asymptotically slower
convergence and I'm just curiously I'm
sort of hearing two different things
like one thing is even for like one
individual question we currently don't
know how to solve it yep and then I'm
also hearing like we need to generate
data that I can use to answer thousands
of questions and I can't reconcile these
things so I don't think I can reconcile
it either but that is the reality of it
so the reality is that users want access
to raw data okay and there has to be a
trade-off between privacy and utility
and we have to decide what that is yes
Adam maybe along similar lines with
criteria are for the disc competition
would it be possible for some set of
applications to write down an explicit
set of criteria for accuracy first these
yes here's this year the first day -
yeah a very specific problem
they don't want this general synthetic
generation but rather they want to check
the three marginal distributions on the
data
okay we're in so many select three
attributes and locate the three marginal
and then you actually check the
clustering or correlation coefficient of
those obvious another data and compare
with real data so that's one concrete I
think they actually use about three
specific tasks for this they care about
a clustering regression and
classification and they specifically
choose data sets where these tasks make
sense on them it's also like very easy
to break down what it means to be
accurate for these three three passes
you asked let's go in general I know
that's a useful answer that's what the
miss challenge but I guess my question
is about those statistics community like
efforts to try and pin down an explicit
accuracy criteria for synthetic data
like it's somehow you know when I read
papers on synthetic either they're
fitting some parametric model okay right
away you're just giving up on everything
except whatever's captured by this
parameter or they're arguing that
somehow they preserve you know what also
useful information I have no idea what
that means
they'll also you know also use like you
know nonparametric models to produce
data and so this is what I was there is
okay so there is not much work on what
you're asking and actually the only and
as far as the general what we call their
general and specific utility measures
for synthetic data what we call specific
utility measures it's very task-oriented
right do i how do i if i want to run the
chi-square test of Independence how well
do I do you know on the synthetic non
synthetic data if I'm if I'm fitting
regression models I
my confidence interval on my from my
synthetic data to overlap
you know significantly now you can ask
me what's significant right with the
regression with with confidence
intervals on my regression estimates
from my original data those are the type
of statistics specific task statistics
that people have been looking in
evaluating the data right now we started
talking more about but we also need more
general measures of utility okay which
rely on distributional comparisons right
and this question of what what I was
saying when we started looking at least
this one measure of this propensity MSE
or you know people have used public
library distance to figure out if the
distribution system are so those are the
type of things that they've been looking
at there is nothing more nothing more
elaborate to to to but that said the
technology has been around for a long
time I am not aware maybe crop the
Falcon knows I'm not aware on any paper
that published their results in their
analysis relying solely on synthetic
data so they are intended for
exploratory purposes and I think I'm not
sure that you can convince somebody for
more than that but I say P I mean yeah
so I think yes no substantive papers
right so I think the way we should be
thinking about when you're saying well
this is contrast right I want these
accuracies here but I want this I think
this is what exactly what you have what
you need to lay out and you say certain
things are only for exploratory purposes
right you're going to get some sense of
accuracy you know if I if you're running
synthetic data and some models depending
how synthetic data are generated which
is going back also to Rachel's point of
she said well for certain things wonder
if she was doing certain analysis things
just didn't work right synthetic data
wasn't valid so she had to continually
to figure out how to update or what to
do right
and so you're gonna go in you're gonna
try things and then maybe you're gonna
figure out okay so these data are not
gonna work for me or I can't do this
type of analysis with these data or I
just have to wait a year until I get
access to the original data unless we
can provide better product that would
somehow address this and I don't have
this is this is a very much open
question and it's been you know open for
a long time and you Adam have asked this
question in 2005 you've asked this
question in 2010 well no because if this
same answer seemed easy for the past you
know 15 years but I don't I think it
publishes to demonstrate the synthetic
data he did not he was not making any
substantive conclusions from it or
things they will make impact policies
great Eusebio Gambetta was particularly
a good choice since the Chinese have it
anyway okay no we should definitely take
a look I I mean as I said I I said I
wasn't aware but it's possible that
there is we should take a look at it
then
it's a good time to freak they should
thank Setia and Rachel and Elsa